In Israel, the military says it has beefed up its troop presence...
...along the border with the Gaza Strip...
...and completed preparation for a possible renewal of hostilities...
...with Palestinian militants.
In Somalia, at least 15 people are dead...
...after a car bomb went off outside a hotel in a busy area of Mogadishu.
In Bangladesh, at least 17 people have been killed...
...after a fire broke out in Dhaka's business district.
Mexico raises the alert for the Popocatepetl volcano as activity intensifies.
Finally, at least 18 people died when a truck slammed into a crowd in western Guatemala.
Police are continuing to search for the truck driver.